[Musique]
il y à 7 ans mon père venait me voir et
me disait dans 72 heures je serai mort
si tu souhaites parler c'est maintenant
ce jour là j'ai pris conscience que
avoir conscience de la mort était le
plus beau cadeau motivationnelle qui
nous ait jamais été offert cédric brout
ingénieurs je rentre de neuf mois de
voyage
quatorze pays à la rencontre
d'entrepreneurs donc plus de 400
rencontres dont 100 entrepreneurs
j'ai réalisé mes rêves pourtant partir à
la poursuite de mes rêves n'a pas
toujours était innée j'ai dû le faire
croître de nourrir le développer chaque
jour et ce soir j'aimerais partager avec
vous les étapes et l'histoire qui m'a
permis de poursuivre mes aspirations
tout commence en 1997 dans la mayenne
verdoyante dans lesquels mes parents
caroline olivier se tombent amoureux
aussi bien de cette campagne de cette
communauté dans lesquelles ils exercent
leur métier de vétérinaire
ils ont deux incroyables enfants dont
moi le cadet vous l'aurez compris et ils
construisent une maison avec toute leur
passion tout leur coeur puisqu'il la
restaure de a à z et cet environnement
et accueillant leur permettent de
développer une vie et menthe pour élever
ses enfants
mais ce matin de 14 juillet 1997 olivier
mon père dit à maman
on est heureux tu ne trouves pas
pourtant quelques heures plus tard lors
d'une fête de village pour un plongeon
stupide dans une piscine mon père se
cassent locaux
diagnostic tétraplégique sous assistance
respiratoire chanceux d'être en vie ce
jour là j'avais uniquement 3 100 jours
de vie à peine neuf mois et pourtant mon
destin ma vie allait changer du tout au
tout car grandir avec un papa roues à
roulettes s'est développée une maturité
différentes s'est développée une
dissociation en quelque sorte aussi bien
émotionnel mais une dissociation par
rapport à la société ce qui
m'intéressait n'était pas le même
intérêt que mes collègues et mes
collègues de collèges particulièrement
où j'arrive dans nos collèges et je me
rends compte d'une chose
l'innocence de l'enfance est finie et
aujourd'hui il faut faire face au regard
de l'autre le regard de l'autre qui a
peur de la différence le regard de
l'autre c'est la première étape à
dépasser pour poursuivre ses rêves et
ses aspirations
puisque on vit dans une société où il
fait bon d'être dans la norme mais la
norme n'est pas les personnes qui sont
remarqués la norme n'est pas l'endroit
où vous allez poursuivre vos rêves et
vos rêves pour vous et c'est le premier
ami que j'ai rencontrés c'est
d'apprendre aller au delà du regard des
autres
mais aller au delà du regard des autres
c'est avant tout aller au delà de la
peur du regard des autres et identifier
ses peurs les comprendre les apprivoiser
c'est pour moi la deuxième étape
primordiale pour poursuivre ses rêves en
effet de quoi avons nous peur
très souvent on dit j'ai peur mais peur
de quoi j'ai peur d'avoir peur étrange
question mais quand l'on réfléchisse à
la raison même de nos peurs quand on
vient disloqué nos peurs en tout ces
différentes étapes
c'est là on peut comprendre le plan
d'action nécessaire pour aller au delà
de nos peurs quand il a fallu partir
neuf mois en voyage à la rencontre de
l'autre tout seul
j'ai été surpris des réactions les gens
ne m'ont pas dit félicitations génial
que vas tu faire ils m'ont dit mais tu
n'as pas peur tu pars tout seul en
amérique latine en asie et c'est là où
j'ai compris que aller au delà de ces
peurs c'est avant tout identifier
qui est ce qui est important pour nous
c'est avant tout de passer à la
troisième
amis pour aller à la découverte de vos
rêves pour aller à la découverte de vos
aspirations et prendre le pas et ce
troisième ami c'est la prise de décision
car si aujourd'hui je suis là devant
vous c'est lié à une prise de décision
si vous êtes là ce soir c'est lié à une
prise de décision
si vous êtes dans cette école c'est lié
à une prise de décision si vous faites
votre métier c'est lié à une prise de
décision décidé c'est prendre la
responsabilité de ses rêves décidé c'est
faire le choix d'aller en avant pour
accomplir ses rêves réellement
l'expérience de mon père m'a fait
prendre conscience de l'importance du
jour l'importance de cinq minutes
l'importance d'être dans le moment
présent également sans obliger
l'aspiration vers ses rêves
la prise de décisions pour moi m'a
permis de maximiser les trois ressources
qui sont les plus importantes dans ma
vie mais dans la vie de tout le monde et
la première c'est les finances la
plupart du temps on travaille 40 heures
70 heures par semaine pour gagner de
l'argent mais combien de temps
réfléchissons nous a commandé pensons
nous notre argent
très souvent 5 10 minutes par semaine
tout au mieux
mais est ce que nos finances sont au
service de nos projets ce que nous
finançons service de nos rêves et si
j'ai pu partir neuf mois en voyage
beaucoup de personnes m'ont dit mais
comment tu finança jeu le finance car
j'ai fait un choix je le finance car
j'ai pris la décision d'investir sur mes
rêves pour mes rêves mais les finances
c'est qu'une première partie de nos
ressources
quand on rencontre tous les grands
entrepreneurs et j'ai la chance d'aller
à trois conférences aux états unis
seraient entrepreneurs les plus cons le
plus de succès ils nous disent le temps
est plus important que l'argent
nous avons tous 24 heures bill gates
vous moi nous avons tous 24 heures est
très souvent on ne réfléchit même pas
comment nous utilisons ces 24 heures 8
heures pour travailler huit heures pour
dormir
il reste huit heures pour aller à la
poursuite de vos rêves certes peut-être
écouter un audio en mangeant lire un
livre écouté une vidéo motivationnelle
dans la voiture vous avez huit heures
pour aller à la poursuite de vos rêves
et c'est ce temps qui encore plus
important que les finances c'est ce
temps qui vous permet de trouver des
solutions des subventions de juste aller
à la poursuite de vos rêves car quand
vous prenez la décision
c'est la première étape
pour rendre un rêve réalité
mais un élément encore plus rares plus
important c'est qu'elle est l'énergie
quand on arrive aux états unis dans un
séminaire d'entrepreneuriat ils nous
disent l'énergie est primordial ils nous
disent vous devez avoir de l'énergie
rien ne se fait sans énergie souvent le
français répond là pas tort pas con mais
derrière quand vous identifiez vos
projets quand vous identifier la prise
de décisions derrière il faut y mettre
de l'énergie car l'énergie vous
permettra de dégager du temps de temps
qui vous permettra dégager de l'argent
également
et ça c'est réellement une des leçons
que j'ai eu également pendant le voyage
car décidé prendre soin de son énergie
c'est en permanence
est ce que je mange ici où est ce que je
mange là bas j'ai un retard dans le
train frustration frustration qui fait
que le père de l'énergie plus souvent à
lutter contre les événements que a lutté
pour trouver une solution
la fameuse énervement voiture au final
on perd beaucoup plus d'énergie à
s'énerver on parle beaucoup plus
d'énergie à réfléchir pourquoi ça s'est
passé que comment je peux faire pour que
ne pas que ça se reproduise mais je vous
entends déjà me dire génial poursuit tes
rêves mais je ne sais pas ce que je veux
faire et on m'a souvent répété je l' ai
souvent entendu je les mets moi-même moi
même dit de nombreuses fois mais je ne
sais pas ce que je vais faire mais je
sais ce que je ne veux pas faire c'est
pas très pratique c'est pas très utile à
vrai dire je sais que je veux pas être
bouché je ne veux pas être tétraplégique
je ne veux pas être médecin ça ne met
pas à savoir quelles sont mes
aspirations à mes rêves
donc j'ai pris du temps le voyage les
neuf mois de voyage c'est également ça à
prendre du temps prendre du temps pour
grandir prendre du temps pour identifier
qu'est ce qui nous fait vivre qu'est ce
qui nous fait nous lever le mât
vous savez quand vous prenez un avion
souvent vous avez pas besoin du réveil
car vous êtes excité et cette excitation
je me suis dit où est ce que je peut la
trouver et avec des lectures avec des
recherches j'ai vu de nombreuses
personnes dire écris tes rêves écris tes
rêves
matin et soir et j'étais sceptique je me
suis dit mais écrire ses rêves ne sert à
rien pourquoi ça marcherait et si je
suis là ce soir devant vous c'est entre
autres parce que j'avais écrit ce rêve
de faire un tedx bien avant que les
organisateurs me fasse l'honneur de me
contacter ce soir car écrire ses rêves
c'est les ancrer dans votre cerveau
conscient mais également dans votre
cerveau se conscient il faut savoir que
le cerveau subconscient et dix mille
fois plus puissant que le cerveau
conscient
si vous vous posez une question au
cerveau conscient il viendra avec une
réponse si vous aussi avec une analyse
de possibilités si vous posez la
question à votre subconscient
il parcourra 10000 option dix mille
possibilités 10000 porri possible et
vous savez c'est ce fameux eureka que
l'on n'attend pas au moment de manger un
burger ou juste de marcher dans la rue
alors qu'on avait même oublié que nous
nous posions la question
écrire ses rêves c'est se donner
l'opportunité de nourrir ce que son
subconscient
c'est l'opportunité de de rendre service
à nos rêves à nos aspirations
la force ultime du subconscient
c'est la visualisation donc seulement
l'écrire mais le sentir le vivre nourrir
au travers la visualisation et je me
souviens très bien d'avoir mon père qui
me répétait de nombreuses fois je serai
plus vivants mort
que dans cette situation que dans cette
prison de serre que dans 7 et rappeler j
il me répétait également j'ai vécu pour
vous voir grandir
or ce 7 mai 2013
le jour de son départ nous étions grands
j'avais 16 ans ce jour là j'ai arrêté de
grandir
j'ai arrêté de grandir en taille mais je
me suis fait une promesse la promesse de
partager cette expérience de partager
cette force qui nous a transmis et de
partager ce message que gandhi a si bien
dit vie comme si tu devais de mourir
demain mais apprend comme si tu veux
devait vivre toujours
c'est dans cette idée que je suis parti
sur les neuf mois de voyage et donc
s'ils allaient au delà du regard de
l'autre m'a permis de partir du cambodge
à hong kong rencontrer des traders ou
des chauffeurs de toc toc
si vaincre mes peurs m'a permis de faire
du stop au chili dans le désert finir
sur scène devant 1800 personnes en
malaisie ou si la simple prise de
décision m'a permis de parler devant
deux entrants 200 entrepreneurs
vénézuélien au pérou m'a permis de
partir ses neuf mois de voyage et
aujourd'hui des présents ce soir le tout
en mettant mes trois ressource
principale au service de mes projets
mais finance mon temps et mon énergie
alors je n'ai plus qu'une question à
vous poser ce soir et si tous ensemble
il n'était plus question d'appréhender
le monde mais de créer son monde
merci
[Applaudissements]